اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من تلي ابيب
اهلا بكم مقتل ثلاثه اسرائيليين واصابه
سبعه في اطلاق نار عند مدخل مستوطنه راموت
بالقدس واستشهاد المنفذين على يد جندي
اسرائيلي وعابر سبيل مسلح وحماس تقول
انهما من عناصر كتائب القسام في الوقت
نفسه يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه جنديين
في عمليه دهس بالاغوار ويطلق النار على
سائق قال انه حاول تنفيذ العمليه ونتنياهو
يؤكد ان الحكومه ستوسع توزيع السلاح على
المواطنين ويقول انه اجراء اثبت
جدوه وفي الضفه الغربيه استشهاد فلسطيني
برصاص قوات الاحتلال في بلده توليا حماس
تقول ان اعدام قناصه الاحتلال طفلين
فلسطينيين خلال اقتحام جنين جريمه مروعه
وتدعو لادانته ومحاسبه القاده
الاسرائيليين رئيس هيئه شؤون الاسرى
الفلسطينيين يقول ان الاحتلال يحول 80% من
معتقلي الضفه للاعتقال الاداري لعدم قدرته
على توجيه تهم
لهم قطر تعلن التوصل الى اتفاق لتمديد
الهدنه المؤقته يوما اضافيا وبلينك يؤكد
من تلي ابيب تاييده استمرار الهدنه بعد ان
اثبتت نجاحا في تامين حريه الرهائن وايصال
المساعدات لغزه مستشار يقول ان الهدنه
ستمدد كل يوم تطلق فيه حماس راح عشر رهائن
احياء الى
اللقاء